it's a really scary time in this country
first pandemic a global pandemic
coronavirus has paralyzed the us economy
isolation was crushing stay at home that
is the order chronovirus crisis
is changing so fast these maps can't
keep up
every day feeling like the last largest
quarantine in the history of the world
feeling alone and powerless as we just
watch the world go by
and fall apart the hideous stay on wall
street a market's plunging brim new
death toll and frightening
new projections feeling like everything
was just out of our control
i am officially declaring a national
emergency this is gonna get
worse before it gets better then that
desolation turned into anger
as the world witnessed what happened to
george floyd breaking news out of
minneapolis black man died
yesterday in police cause jordan floyd
repeatedly told the officers that he
could protest
flashing with police in minneapolis it
is unbelievable to see what is happening
in almost every single major city in
this country if we want change our
generation has to step up right now
after seeing what i saw today my blood
is boiling right now
i saw them tear gas a whole crowd of
people's day
for peacefully walking tomorrow
tuesday june 2nd we are hosting a
basketball
peaceful protest in philly we are
bringing the hoop out
we are going to ball in the streets
because that is the best way i know how
to spread love
that is the best way i know how to bring
people together
just the idea of going out during these
times was
really really nerve-wracking like i
didn't know how people were gonna take
it
i wanted people to understand right from
the start what i was doing and why i was
doing it
we're trying to bring this city back
together that's what this is for right
now
sports
i also wanted them to understand that
like i was paying attention to coven 19
and
was trying to take precautions in that
as well i had masks for people if they
wanted them i had hand sanitizer
got out there all the anxiety and
nervousness kind of faded as soon as the
first person started to play
you don't want to give me a jump shot
i'm telling you right now
[Music]
me and my brother we was actually
downtown protesting and we just happened
to see her and she said you guys want to
take a shot
her whole goal is for everyone just to
come together and have fun and enjoy
like you know have a good time i was
just playing with five people i've never
met before in my entire life
and i may see them again i may not but
for that few moments we were playing
together we reunited as one
playing really kind of eased the tension
of the crowd
i saw people coming in passionately
protesting right which is important
but then when they came to us you know a
big smile came up on their face
you're like oh it's a hoop like i want
to play too people drive by
smiling like get out the car run and
take a shot want to play basketball
she's probably she brings people
together he's gonna pick you up look how
tall he is
right up to the basket
[Music]
[Applause]
then you can play with me sometimes
right people always say like ball is
life and like that's like
very true for me you know there's
nothing in the world that i love more
than basketball
it's kind of the one thing that kept me
together
as a kid when i was born i wasn't
supposed to be able to walk
so my legs were turned completely in so
i had cast on for the first three years
of my life
a lot of my memories growing up were
just me being in a lot of pain
the doctor said maybe we'll get her
walking again but she'll never be able
to play sports or
you know run or anything like that my
parents didn't really like that answer
and they put me in every sport possible
and i guess
basketball just kind of stuck the
struggle helped me appreciate
being able to play basketball the most
every time i walk on a court
i'm just happy that i can go out there
and play the way that i play
okay
hey we got the w nobody can check her
people take her lightly because she's a
girl but she pretty much
ends up beating him i'm six foot four
i've been playing basketball my entire
life
do not sleep on that girl trust me
[Music]
[Applause]
when i see police officers i pretty much
call them out and i'm like you want a
ball
you want to play you want to play me
like let's go
let's play that
initial person will break that ice
and then all the police officers want to
take a shot or they want to somehow get
involved
it's a real good thing for the city and
to bring people together of all ages
i'm almost 50 years old so i'm out here
playing with kids
protesters and cops playing one-on-ones
want 2-2 just
just talking i think that's very
powerful to me that speaks volumes
if you think that bringing out a hoop
will start changing
attitudes and that will bring people
together i said go ahead girl
do that i hope more people do positive
things like this
so that we can bring our city of
philadelphia community as well as around
the world back together
i've had people come to me being like
why are you playing with the police
i think the problem with that is
yelling at the police officers wasn't
going to create the change
we're all in this community together
it's all about just
breaking that tension creating like a
place for people to be able to
come out and just be happy and enjoy
themselves
just something about a basketball like
just friendly it's like a universal
language
we're so glad you're here hey i
appreciate you i really do believe that
sports can bring people together
and unite people i've seen how all these
people of
different like races ethnicities gender
ages everything right they all come
together and they're all standing around
watching or they want to get involved
bringing a basketball hoop is not going
to end racism i
100 know that that's not the case we're
just trying to break the tension so that
maybe we can come together as a
community and find the right solutions
to get to a better place in our country
in our society